[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game
from the sharjah masters 2019 it comes
as a suggestion from user aman kohli so
thanks for that
i've never seen this game and i don't
know how i've missed it as
it's really uh well i don't know if it's
uh indeed
firouj is immortal but you guys will be
the judge of that uh amancali suggested
the game
well saying that this is probably
alireza's immortal uh so without further
ado let's check it out alex's opponent
is
uh from round one of the 2019 charger
masters
milo jacob which uh uh international
master women's international master from
serbia
and it's quite an amazing game and i
just realized my board is again
uh weird so let me just fix that there
we go
yeah i don't know sometimes the
interface does this
uh uh without further ado let's check it
out uh furuja with
the white pieces opens uh with e4
uh we have c5 the sicilian defense is on
the board
uh knight to f3 d6 and now c3 ferruja
goes for the
uh close sicilian for the moment uh we
have
a6 uh and now g3 preparing to think it
with the light square bishop
uh we have b5 emilia does the same she
wants to play bishop to b7 grab hold of
this diagonal and now alireza doesn't
fiance to the bishop but rather strikes
in the center with
d4 so he opens up the position uh and
here
c captures on d4 there is one game in
the database where b4 was actually
played it was from 1987
in a game between grigori serper and
igor novikov where serper
was able to win this game very easily
uh sort of sort of a miniature uh and
also it was the
the year i was born if anyone's
interested but other than b4 here in
this game we have c
captures on d4 uh we have knight
captures
and now just bishop to b7 developing the
light square bishop
so of course the bishop to g2 continuing
development adding more protection to
the center
and knight the f6 now we have castles by
ferruja
and now e6 uh and now rook to e1 and if
you look at this position it seems like
everything is perfectly fine for both
white and black black can just play
bishop e7 castles bring the knight into
the game
so everything is you know as it should
be but it's not that
that simple because here if you just
continue uh without uh thinking that
there's
anything to the position you might play
something like bishop to e7
and this loses on the spot because now
e5 and there's a double attack here and
here
and it doesn't matter what you play uh
if you capture the bishop let's say
bishop captures it then just uh
he captures an f6 and again you've
traded pieces but both of black's
bishops are under attack and
you're just gonna have to give up one of
them and if you don't give up
uh the uh give it up like that you might
play something like
bishop uh well you could even play this
but it doesn't matter yes you are
attacking the knight here
bishop captures attacks the rook so e
captures on d4 you're gonna pick up the
rook here
and after for example the captures here
you're gonna trade queens characters
captures and now anything for white
it doesn't really matter the position
will be winning as white
is up up the exchange and black doesn't
really have anything to show for
so instead after rook to e1 uh we have
knight f2d7 here
making uh making a very serious decision
saying that the king will be staying in
the center of the board for
uh quite some time other than this you
might play something like queen d7 just
add protection to this bishop and then
continue development
but okay knight after d7 uh and now
comes
a4 first just says all right your king
is in the center of the board time to
time to open up some uh files the the
idea is that if b4 which is kind of
intuitive you you want to push respond
to b4 really mess up
white's uh you know uh harmony uh
between between pieces but the problem
is knight d5 is coming
and this is just bad for black there's
really no
not a good developing move and of course
capturing the knight is uh
off limits then you just recapture with
check from the rook and
now it doesn't matter if bishop e7
knight f5 just wins the game
and if you don't do bishop p7 you might
try knights the e5 block the line
and block the file like this but then
just f4 attack the pin piece and that's
that's it so instead after a4 we have
just b
captures on a4 and now rook captures on
a4
this is not necessary but ferruja has a
very very
uh clear idea of of what he's doing
uh we have bishopka e7 i will remind you
it is
as of move 11 now that this position has
never been reached again
and now well you could continue with
knight to d5 here it might be
a bit too a bit too soon because if you
go for this idea now then just captures
captures and the problem is the bishop
is already on e7
knight f5 it doesn't really uh sorry
after knight e5
there really is no threat if f4 the
knight comes to g6
the knight now also defends the bishop
on e7 knight f5
doesn't really do anything you can just
castle and black is perfectly fine here
so furuja goes for the bish for the rook
the b4 attacking the bishop
on b7 that's the the plan rook a4 to b4
uh and now you could uh move uh well you
can't really
move the bishop you could play something
like bishop to c6 it looks a bit
passive then the knight can be developed
you could play rook to
a7 that's one option miller goes for a
knight to c5 and it does make sense uh
the defense the bishop on b7 this is an
excellent square for the knight
next you're going to castle and
everything is perfectly fine but not
really
if you had something else in mind so
feel free to pause the video here and
figure out what alireza uh played here
while i give you a couple of seconds and
uh if i forgot to mention
these are all classical games an hour
and a half for the entire game plus 30
seconds increment per move
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
not doing anything weird and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
knights the f5 is fine but there is a
a forcing way to do things here and
that's rook captures on b7
uh that's that's the movalizer played
with knight captures on b7 you have to
recapture
and now only now e5 opening up an attack
towards the
knight here and the problem is uh you
don't really gain anything by closing
the position
uh this is what what mila played as it
does seem to be the only move but
there really isn't anything better here
felicia just continues happily
attacking with knight captures on d5 and
now
uh while you want to just allow white to
remain here you want to castle the
safety and say okay
you know just leave me alone even that
doesn't work because here if you just
ignore white and just
castle here comes knight captures on e7
with check queen captures and now queen
to g4
really really awesome uh the queen
aligns with the king
uh the bishop still slicing over through
this diagonal and well ideas like bishop
to g5 to f6 are coming so
sort of to play it out for you you could
try something like rook to a7 try to
activate those pieces on the queen side
but
this just loses terribly like i said
bishop g5
attacks the queen and there's not much
if queen eight just bishop f6
threatens checkmate and if g6 is just
queen g5 and there is no defense against
queen h6 the g7 checkmate
so what you could do for example after
queen g4 is ignore everything on the
queen side
play something like king to h8 at least
bishop to h6 now
is not an idea but still bishop to g5
attacks the queen and after the queen
moves
now you go queen to h5 uh and
bishop to e4 is coming and this just
shows how strong the
the bishop perry is for example knight
d7 you're going to bring the bishop to
e4
threat and checkmate and after g6 queen
h6 and again
what do you play here uh queen captures
an e5 let's say
grabbing that pawn the queen can also
help out with the defense
knight to f3 now attacking the queen
queen to g7
and now okay black defended but now you
start collecting that queen side
that black uh had to leave undefended
for example rook a7 now bishop goes back
to e4
and white is just better here if
captures captures does it really matter
uh whatever black plays you have two
bishops for a rook two bishops for a
rook is
quite enough and this will be completely
winning for white not only that white
already has a past
c pawn so after uh alireza played this
knight captures on d5 there really is no
way to decline it you you have to accept
it if you want to continue this game
so e captures on v5 was played but now
comes
knight to f5 and this is all just very
very confusing what is alireza even
doing
uh okay he's attacking the g7 pawn if
that falls with
check then let's say king of fade bishop
to h6 you get the idea everything is
you know falling into place so you can't
really allow this so here
castles this is in fact the strongest
move by black but it is insufficient
bishop captures on d5 now so again
what do you play here uh well it's not
easy uh that night that knight is still
hanging there uh if the queen moves
this knight can pick up the bishop with
check the queen is still coming to g4
there's going to be some checkmating
threats here bishop coming to h6 always
an option
so how do you defend this uh well here
mila played bishop to c5 it does make
sense get the knight away from the
uh from the uh get the bishop away from
the knight so it cannot be captured also
you're threatening that f2 square so you
if the file opens up you might have some
pressure along the f file
and it controls the knight here very
very nicely uh however
here alireza plays uh one of the
greatest moves
ever so uh i i i could ask you to pause
the video here but i'm not going to i'm
just going to show you the move and then
explain it to you because it's just
super super difficult you you can't
pause the video if you want i mean i
can't really stop you but
uh here alerissa played b4 and b4
is such an amazing move uh b4 is often
the the greatest move in any position
you know when when you're playing white
uh so you know keep that in mind but
here it's just
so strong uh the the point is alireza
wants to play bishop the
queen to g4 go after that g7 uh the idea
if you go after it now uh then black
defends with the g6
and now what do you play okay you could
go for knight to h6 with
check then the king goes here and then
bishop to g5
this is of course possible and this will
be winning for example f6
you can play e captures on f6 but now
rook captures and all of a sudden
while white is still winning you have
some worries here the bishop attacks the
f2 pawn
and you have to still uh you know work
out how how you're going to win this
game and while this is completely
winning and the furuja could win this
he wanted something more he wanted here
in this hypothetical position after
queen g4 g6
uh he wanted to play e6 but e6 here does
not work e6 here does not work
because the queen just picks up the
bishop on d5 and now you don't really
have anything if you capture on f7 rook
captures and black is perfectly fine not
only that black is winning
and this is where the b4 move comes uh
comes to mind b4 and now all of uh
alireza's ideas become possible here the
problem is the b4
pawn cannot be captured if you capture
on b4 then
queen g4 will also attack the bishop
while
threatening checkmate and now after g6
you're going to go knight to h6 check
king to g7
and now bishop to g5 attack that queen
and now the point is uh if queen
captures and b5
then it's not a problem just bishop f6
check a king captures an h6 and now
queen
to h3 will be checkmate so the queen
cannot
capture on d5 here after this but f6 can
be played
and now the the problem is that the
bishop is on b4 you just capture on f6
rook captures and now you pick up this
bishop and
well black is completely tied down here
if you go for this
bishop grab queen captures on the e5
just rookie seven check
king to h8 and let's say bishop captures
on f6 will be checkmate
so this does not work after b4 b4 you
cannot capture it you have to do
something else so here
mila goes back bishop to b6 but now now
alireza's plan
uh can be uh can be completely uh you
know
fulfilled he plays queen to g for g6
and now now the move becomes possible as
the bishop is now here and
not guarding that e7 square here just
e6 and that's the point the e6 is just
crushing
and the point is now the queen cannot
capture here because there's no bishop
on c5 guarding e7 just 97 check and oh
you lose the queen so here after e6
queen to
f6 was played but now uh while you can
win this position in many ways
uh for example there is a very nice idea
of just e captures on f7 with
king h8 and the rook e6 clearing the
queen
uh from that f6 square basically we want
to clear this diagonal and once the
queen moves doesn't really matter where
queen d8 bishop b to check and that's it
you just you just lose
you have to start giving up material and
then it's going to be checkmate it
doesn't really matter
so here after this queen to f6 well you
could do that alireza went for the
for the even simpler idea e7 the rook is
under attack and now there's nothing to
be done here
rookie 8 was played but now feel free to
pause the video and try to find the move
that
ends the game on the spot while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on again
not doing anything weird like capturing
this night i mean there's
this is no time to be capturing nights
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop captures on
f7 with
check this is what eliza played and it
was in this position that mila resigned
in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh problem is
you could capture with the queen you
could capture with the king you could
move the king
while all of this is possible none of it
works for example if queen captures it
just knights the h6 with
check and you're not even interested in
winning the queen because after king g7
you're gonna play bishop b to check
uh king captures and now just queen to h
for checkmate the bishop controls this
entire diagonal so the king is unable to
go back
and if you don't capture with the queen
you might capture with the king but it's
also insufficient
just queen to c4 with check and the king
has no moves this is covered by the pawn
this is covered by the knight this is
covered by the queen
so you have to block here and then just
queen captures will be checkmate
and uh the third option after bishop
captures an f7 check
is king the h8 but this is also
insufficient
now we just uh you know uh okay you you
don't get checkmated but you suffer
tremendously after bishop captures on e8
uh you just lose the look
once the bishop moves the pawn is
promoting it doesn't really matter what
you do if
if knight b6 let's say you go after the
bishop to control the queening square
you just move the bishop with tempo
wherever it doesn't really matter
you just want to queen this pawn and if
black does not allow this let's say
knight c6
guards the queening square now twice you
just play anything
bishop b2 attacks the queen there that
that's it
uh queen captures here you're just gonna
play queen to h4 and there's no
defending checkmate
uh whatever you do you're getting
checkmated or you could play some weird
moves like
queen g7 knight captures queen but we're
not gonna
cover those moves uh so after bishop
captures on f7
uh miller resigned and uh an amazing
amazing game by feruja
from the first round of the 2019 charge
of masters and i don't know how i missed
this game it's really weird that such a
game would elude me
uh because you know i'm a huge fan of
uh you know such games uh i don't even
remember this i know i was following the
games from the
sharjah masters i i think from the
previous three years
but you know uh uh it eluded me so thank
you very much
uh to aman kohli for suggesting this
game as it's quite an amazing one
uh sure so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
vrokopsic uh mr hoodie guy
john nicely laura waldrop and juan pablo
barrera for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
weekend